now it's my pleasure to introduce my
friend and most importantly the
president of Hillsdale College dr. Larry
yarn dr. Arnn received his BA in 1974
from Arkansas State University we
learned last night that he may have had
a dog bite when he when he received his
degree but he went on to graduate the
highest highest distinction he also
received his MA in government 1976 in
his PhD in government in 1985 from
Claremont Graduate School dr. Arnn has
numerous accomplishments those include
his services research director of the
official biographer of Winston Churchill
sir martin gilbert and president of the
claremont institute he has served on
numerous governing boards including the
Heritage Foundation declare Mount
Institute in the Army War College Board
of Visitors since coming to Hillsdale
College in two thousand the college has
grown to national prominence through his
outstanding economic program academic
programs and principal defense of our
Constitution dr. Arnn is married to his
lovely lovely wife Penny and they have
four children katie henry allison tony
please welcome dr.
thank you most warmly Chris Chris hadn't
mentioned it because he makes
Republicans mad all the time but he's
the head of the club for growth and and
in that he does really great work and
that's what makes Republicans med and
one piece of great work he's done is
happens to be an old friend of mine
who's I've guess I've known him since
well before he was born and he's running
for Congress and he's going to get
elected he's in a seat down in Arkansas
where he's going to win and you know of
course I'm from Arkansas and that means
that this man and I are cousins and that
means he's a candidate to marry my
sister or something but because he's
that in this awful he's getting ready to
introduce a new yorker by the way and
he's thinking right now what is this you
know and he's everything about this guy
is incredibly weird he he's a graduate
of Harvard College in harvard law school
I've known him since he was in the law
school and what a few years ago I got a
letter from him and he said he wanted me
to write to the army for him because he
decided he wanted to go serve his
country and they wanted to put him in
the judge advocates general branch she's
a fancy lawyer but no no he wanted to
fight and so I wrote a letter to him and
said that look you got to put this guy
in the trenches because he wants to get
shot and if he doesn't get shot he'll
end up being some good for the country
so it's an excellent investment what
does it cost you if he does get shot and
and he patrolled the streets of Fallujah
and he was the old guard guarding the
Tomb of the Unknown Soldier and I can't
stop he's a really great guy his name is
Tom cotton please stand up
and when he gets in the Congress and he
does some stupid thing then write me and
I will take care of it because I thank
you all for being here most warmly I
hope you saw this morning we had some
good fights and it was a the kind that
can lead to the truth and so we're
getting somewhere and I hope you saw
Charles Kessler's presentation at lunch
today because it ties into the
introduction I have to make tonight he
said that modern liberalism of
progressivism which is in the in the
course of transforming our country for
good or for ill but certainly very
dramatically has preceded in these three
wives and now Obama is a fourth and he
says that the new freedom under Woodrow
Wilson in the New Deal under Franklin
Roosevelt and the Great Society under
linda johnson were the first three waves
and he said it's peculiar about them
that they stopped for a long hiatus
after each one of them made what they
call progress change things a lot and in
the next one more in the next one more
and then there was a pause it raises the
interesting question how would you make
something more than a pause are we on
this ratchet that we like to talk about
some time or is there the kind of
progress possible that would come after
there was a return and there hasn't
really been any experience of return at
least not fully but there been these
pauses and it's possible the way back
towards some return could be found in
how the pauses were achieved and I
believe that myself that every great and
stable thing that happens in politics
any long-term durability of good in
politics always comes from the
combination of two forces I think I have
learned this from winston churchill i
think this is how he looked at the world
i think one of those forces is
constitutionalism constitutionalism is a
forum for government
gives it stability it gives patterns
through which it works it shapes how
people work in it and therefore it
affects their characters and a good
Constitution elevates those characters
and the other force is an opposite kind
of force if constitutionalism has to do
with procedures and stable going along
and checking the will of people at any
given moment because they must act if
they're going to act effectively in a
certain way and not just at that moment
necessarily the way they want to act the
other force is opposite to pre
constitutionalism then it's
statesmanship it's what highly effective
and driven people do when they're good
at details and they can make things
happen Adolf Hitler learned to his cost
that it was a mistake to get into a war
with Winston Churchill it cost him his
life Winston Churchill was a lethal man
and if you knew what he was like when he
was a boy three times decorated in war
by the time he was 26 and then
immediately the author of best-selling
books about the war that became the
chief way that anybody in his country
knew about the war and shaped what they
thought and Churchill was a second
lieutenant which means the generals were
really cranky about that there's
something about that guy that just could
not be stopped and he was always like
that he was captured once and marched
through the rain at gunpoint and went
for a day and a half on a train and got
to the capital of prisoner war of South
Africa Pretoria and they have to take a
picture of him alongside a bunch of
other soldiers and all the rest of them
had their heads down and they were
drooping and there was this one guy and
he didn't know his picture was off was
being taken but he was standing off at
the side and he was looking at them with
contempt and his chin was up just like
that and the point is you want to get in
a war like that fear that man
he will kill you the greatest of such
men are always supporters of
constitutionalism George Washington was
such a man crossed the Delaware River on
Christmas night and wake up a bunch of
enemy soldiers and try to kill them in
their beds after their Christmas revels
in order to get some kind of victory to
hang on for a few more months
ruthlessness but always coupled with
restraint in the great ones and that
twin combination is simply essential and
if we look back through these three
pauses because there's no pause yet in
the fourth of the waves of liberalism we
look back to two things that have
produced at least the pauses and my Tim
principal produce the return and one of
them is the obvious operation of the
Constitution the United States takes
time to get anything done under it and
liberalism gets these spurts but they
get checked because you can't do it all
at once and the other is statesmanship
what statesmen can we find if we look
back through this history of America
when it has been changed so much
obviously the name of Ronald Reagan
comes up it's encouraging to think about
that name because he was behind in the
middle of September in 1980 I'm not
making any particular topical reference
there
but you would also have to include our
speaker tonight his story is the story
of these years in the second two waves
he's a graduate of Columbia of Cambridge
of the Jewish Theological Seminary he's
won many awards including the
Presidential Medal of Freedom he's
authored 12 books they're all worth
reading I've read about half of them he
served his country in the army from 1953
255 he was editor-at-large of commentary
magazine and then promoted
editor-in-chief which job he proceeded
to do for 35 years during that time
commentary magazine became a force to
stop the advance of communism and the
advance of liberalism in our country and
it had not been that before the day he
became its editor in the 1970s he
founded the committee on the present
danger and that was just about the time
when landed Brezhnev gave an illegal
speech in Berlin violation of several
treaties the correlation of forces
speech and he stopped in the middle of
the speech and Mick jets flew over to
emphasize in that that's what was it
legal flew over to emphasize the point
of the speech which is the correlation
of forces has shifted in our favor and
now the world is going to begin to
conform to our will that's what he had
to say and it's at that time and those
series events in the administration of
James Carter which is also the
administration that started its assault
upon our College back in the same years
the lead to forming formation of this
little committee here's the time for me
to say that this man is married to one
of my favorite people I've known her for
getting on 30 years now
adore her and think that she is tougher
than her husband and when I'm done
describing her husband you'll know that
that's very tough indeed her name is
Mitch dictor
their lives are a conversion story of a
kind but I've always thought from coming
to know them that the love of decency
and freedom that is native to them it
doesn't really amount to a conversion
they just got instructed about some
stuff that they hadn't understood when
they were younger he did one of the most
fine and defiant things I know because I
can remember in 1982 when he published
an article i'm about to quote from my
teacher Harry Jaffa who adores Norman
he's one of those few men that Jaffa
would talk to his students about always
of course to point out alongside Milton
Friedman another one that of course
professor Jaffa is much smarter and more
right than these guys but these guys are
really great you gotta know professor
Jaffa but if you do know him you'll know
that that's exactly what he's like and
he can't one time he came and I was
working at the Claremont institute in
those days and wouldn't wasn't the
president of it yet and he SAT me down
and he read me most of a long article
and commentary magazine called jacooz
the name comes from a famous article by
emile zola in france in 1898 he was a
staunch defender Zola was of the French
Republic at that time and a and a kind
of figure of French establishment and
this man an officer by the name of
Dreyfus was accused of treason and
prosecuted and Zola was sure that this
was wrong and so he went on the line to
accuse the French government broadly of
anti-semitism which led eventually to
the rescue and the freedom of the
reputation and the liberation from
prison of Dreyfus his article doesn't
accuse the United States exactly but the
West itself because this is at a time
when Israel and such a time by the way
have you read the newspapers lately is
about as right now when it's in mortal
peril
and that peril has become more acute
than the regular acuteness that they
live under all the time and you have to
know about that place by the way this is
tiny little place if you're any good at
all you can write a bicycle the length
of it in a day and you can trot the
width of it in a day that's what the
size of it is and so there isn't any
room and since I'm on about it i will
tell you because i happen to know a lot
about this because i used to work for
martin gilbert that the same set of
promises were made in the First World
War that if the Ottoman Empire should go
away that some Jews would be given the
country and there'd be some Arab
countries and the service they had to do
was to fight against the Ottomans
alongside the Western Allies and the
Arabs Got in many countries out of this
and the Jews got one and the one that
they got and I'm missing this for a
reason because it comes up a lot lately
and nobody knows the basic facts and yet
they're terribly simple and there were
many plans about what the size of the
Jewish country should be and the plan
that was it what that was finally
selected was the smallest of all of the
possible plans and in fact the place
that was selected is objectively or an
absolute turn simply tiny and so it's
difficult to think in what corner of the
world could they be placed in their
escape from the Holocaust and their hope
to be protected in it letter later
except in that pitiful little bitty
place that's what they've been given and
they're not being given any more this
article contains a quote and it goes way
beyond the issue of Israel which I'm
going to leave now and I'm going to talk
about something that involves every one
of us every living human being for as
long by the way his recorded history
exist hostility writes our speaker
tonight toward Israel is a sure sign of
the failing faith in and support for the
virtues and values of Western
civilization in general and of America
in particular and this reminds me of
something that Winston Churchill wrote
it's also terribly like something that
a political philosopher Leo Strauss
wrote I have to tell you the joke that's
at the beginning of this paragraph
because Churchill liked the Jews a lot
and he knew them very well and the
paragraph begins it has been well said
that wherever there are three Jews it
will be found that there are two prime
ministers and one leader of the
opposition they are as God said a
stiff-necked people Churchill continues
later in the paragraph no two cities
have counted more with mankind than
Athens and Jerusalem their messages in
religion philosophy and art have been
the main guiding lights of modern faith
and culture centuries of foreign rule
and indescribable endless oppression
leave them still living active
communities and forces in the model
modern world quarreling of course among
themselves with insatiable vivacity
personally Churchill writes I have
always been on the side of both and
believed in their invincible power to
survive internal strife and the world
tides threatening their extinction
what's at stake you know is the wish of
people to live in a society that is
oriented upwards toward the best things
in freedom and peace and culture and
learning and art and civility the West
has produced that because of the
teachings that come from those two
cities and when we forget that we forget
ourselves and we stand the chance of
losing what is best in ourselves and the
man that I introduced you to now is to
you now is like Winston Churchill a
constitutionalist who is also a state at
a statesman which is a synonym remember
always for a warrior Norman put horns
I'm an octogenarian you have to forgive
me that was quite an introduction I i
love flattering introduction so i must
say this is about the most flattering
I've ever been subjected to and one of
the reasons I love flowering
introductions is not just because they
tickle my vanity but also because they
give me an opportunity to set you
smoothly into the telling of one of my
favorite jokes which is of course a
Jewish joke it takes place in an unusual
venue which is a deathbed of an ancient
rabbi who is surrounded by his disciples
and students who are weeping and wailing
and tearing their clothes at the
imminent demise of their rabbi and one
of them says oh how will we survive the
death of our rabbi he is the most
learned man of the age and who will be
there to teach us when he is gone and a
second said how will we survive the
death of our rabbi he is the most moral
man of the age and who will set us an
example of ethical conduct when he is
gone and the third said how will we
survive the death of our rabbi is the
wisest man of the age and who will show
us the path of wisdom when he is gone
and they weep and they wail in the old
man with the last ounce of strength and
his failing body lifts himself up in his
elbow and says and about my humility you
have nothing to say well I
I regret to notice that Larry had
nothing to say about my humility but
I'll have to suffer that gracefully I
was asked and delighted to respond to
speak tonight on the subject of is
America exceptional which is what I am
about to do once upon a time hardly
anyone dissented from the idea that for
better or worse the United States of
America was different from all other
nations this isn't surprising since the
attributes that made it different were
vividly evident from the day of its
birth perhaps the most detailed and the
deepest analysis of these attributes can
be found in Larry Owens beautiful book
the founders key but let me say a few
words about three of them in particular
first of all unlike all other nations
past or present this one accepted as
self-evident truth that all men were
created equal how would this meant was
that the founders aim to create a
society in which for the first time in
the history of the world the individuals
fate would be determined not by who his
father was but by his own freely truth
chosen pursuit of his own ambitions in
other words America was to be something
entirely new Under the Sun a society in
which hereditary status and class
distinctions would be erased leaving
individuals free to act and to be judged
on their own merits alone now they
remained of course the to add a Vista
contradictions of slavery and the
position of women but so intolerable did
they ultimately prove that they had to
be resolved even though in the case of
one of them if it took fighting the
bloodiest war the nation had and still
has ever fought secondly
in all other countries membership or
citizenship was a matter of birth of
blood of lineage of rootedness in the
soil from this had followed that
foreigners who might have been admitted
for one reason or another could never
become full-fledged members of the
society but America was the incarnation
of an idea and therefore no such factors
came into play to become a full-fledged
American neither birth nor lineage was
required it was only necessary to pledge
allegiance to the New Republic and to
the principles for which it stood
thirdly in all other nations the rights
if any enjoyed by their citizens were
conferred by human agencies kings and
princes and occasionally Parliament's as
such these rights amounted to privileges
and therefore could be revoked at will
by the same human agencies in America by
sharp contrast the citizens rights were
declared from the very beginning to have
come from God and to be inalienable that
is immune to legitimate revocation or
cancellation or qualification by any
human agency as I say these and all the
other ways in which America was
exceptional were obvious to just about
everyone from the beginning now to be
sure they're always been sporadic
efforts to change or reverse the
revolutionary course to which the
signers of the Declaration of
Independence pledged their lives their
fortunes and their sacred honor and to
whose lofty Jeffersonian words the
Constitution later gave Madisonian flesh
the most influential of these
counter-revolutionary efforts was and is
the progressive movement whose
development from Woodrow Wilson to
Barack Obama is brilliantly traced as
Larry has mentioned in Charles Kessler's
new book I am the change nevertheless
and in defiance of such courage
turns the course mapped out by the
founders has in principle at least
remained the mandatory national
direction to this very day a good
contemporary case in point was
affirmative action by resurrecting the
hereditary considerations explicitly
repudiated by the Declaration and then
updating them with race and gender
replacing blood and lineage affirmative
action flew in the face of perhaps the
most revolutionary of the ideas on which
the American Republic was founded yet so
powerful a hold that this idea retain on
the American mind that the proponents of
affirmative action were forced to
pretend that it was somehow faithful to
the principle of individual merit be
that as it may as time went on other
characteristics that were unique to
America gradually manifested themselves
for instance in the 20th century social
scientists began speculating on why
America was the only country in the
developed world where socialism had
failed to take root as it happens I
myself first came upon the term American
exceptionalism not in Alexis de
Tocqueville democracy in America where
it has mistakenly been thought to have
originated but in a book by the
sociologist Seymour Martin lipsett who
used it in connection with the absence
in America of a strong Socialist Party
more recently I've discovered that it
may actually have been Joseph Stalin of
all people who coined the term in the
same connection but that he did so only
to dismiss it that's when an American
Communist leader informed him that
American workers had no intention of
playing the role Marx had assigned to
the worldwide proletariat as the
vanguard of the coming socialist
revolution Stalin reputedly shouted
something like away with this heresy of
American exceptionalism and yet Stalin
and his followers were themselves
exceptional and denying that America was
exceptional and the plainly observables
sense of being different in many
respects from all the other nations in
the world if however almost everyone
agree that America was different there
was a great deal of disagreement over
the question of whether this
exceptionalism made it into a force for
good or a force for evil this too went
back to the beginning when the Dean I
graders far outnumbered the enthusiasts
at first anti-american passions were
understandably fueled by the dangerous
political challenge posed to the
monarchies of Europe by the democratic
or more precisely the Republican ideas
of the American Revolution but the
political side of anti-americanism was
soon joined to a cultural indictment
that proved to have more staying power
so much more that in one form or another
it has persisted up to this very moment
here's how the volatile but brilliant
historian Henry Adams the descendant of
two American presidents John Adams was
his great-grandfather and John Quincy
Adams his grandfather here's how Henry
Adams once described the cultural
indictment as it was framed in the
earliest days of the Republic in the
foreigners range of observation Adams
wrote love of money was the most
conspicuous and the most common trait of
the American character no foreigner of
that day neither poet painter or
philosopher could detect an American
life anything higher than vulgarity
Englishman especially indulge an
unbounded invective against the sordid
character of American society
contemporary critics could see neither
generosity economy honor nor ideas of
any kind in the American breasts well in
his younger days Henry Adams defended
the America of 1800 1800 against these
foreign critics but he himself
snobbishly recoiling from the changes
wrought by the rapid industrialization
of the country following the Civil War
would later hurl the very same charge at
the America of the so-called Gilded Age
we see a similar conflict in Tocqueville
writing about the America of 1830 his
great book democracy in America was
mainly a defense of the country's
political system and many of its
egalitarian habits and mores but where
its cultural and spiritual life was
concerned Tocqueville expressed much the
same contempt as the critic cited by
Henry Adams the Americans he wrote with
their exclusively commercial habits were
so fixated upon purely practical objects
that they neglected the pursuit of
science literature and the arts and it
was only their proximity to Europe that
allowed them to neglect these pursuits
without lapsing into barbarism well many
years later another frenchman georges
clemenceau went Tocqueville one better
in denied raiding the cultural side of
American exceptionalism America he
quipped is the only nation in history
which miraculously has gone from
barbarism to decadence without the usual
interval of civilization the French
should talk the main reason for the
enduring power of the cultural critique
was its fervent embrace beginning in the
Gilded Age by the vast majority of the
writers artists and intellectuals who
follow Tocqueville and his predecessors
in lamenting the indifference and even
hostility to things of the Spirit on the
part of American society at large and so
it still goes in 2012 when in various
versions the putative materialism and
crassness of American life are harped
upon in movies television shows novels
volumes of social criticism and op-ed
pieces too numerous to count like
Tocqueville and the foreigners cited by
Henry Adams moreover such works
attribute this crassly Philistine
attitude to the love of money and the
exclusively commercial habits
that went with it in other words to the
species of freedom that has done more
than anything else ever invented to lift
masses of people out of poverty and that
would later be known as capitalism
America then these critics were
declaring was exceptional or write
exceptionally bad and even downright
evil well on the other hand they've
always been defenders of the belief that
American exceptionalism was a vital
force for good several decades before
changing his mind and switching sides
Henry Adams charged the foreign critics
of America with blindness to the
country's amazing virtues whereas adams
wrote European philosophers and poets
could see only rapacity and vulgarity in
America the poorest Europeans peasants
could discern in Adams his word words
that the hard practical money-getting
American Democrat was in truth living in
a world of dream and was already guiding
nature with a kinder and wiser hand than
had ever yet been felt in human history
it was this dream Adams went on to say
that beckoned to the poor of the old
world calling upon them to come and
share in the limitless opportunities had
offered and that were unimaginable
anywhere else for a long time now to
speak personally as some of you may know
I am notorious for doing I've taken my
stand with the young Adams to whom
America was exceptionally good against
his embittered older self to whom it had
become exceptionally bad in my own
younger days I was on the left and from
the utopian vantage point to which
leftism invariably transports its
adherence it was the flaws in American
society the radical sixties Trinity of
war races in the poverty that stood out
most vividly it rarely occurred to me or
my fellow left us to ask a simple
question compared to what was America so
bad after all from our modern
perspective much more was wrong with
Periclean Athens or the Italy of the
meta cheese or England under the first
Queen Elizabeth when 19th century Russia
under the Romanovs but this has not
disqualified them from being universally
ranked among the very highest points of
human civilization and achievement after
more than 40 years of pondering the
question compared to what I have come to
believe with all my heart that the
United States of America belongs on that
exalted list we haven't earned a place
on it as the others mainly did by our
contribution to the arts in this respect
we have never fulfilled the dream of
John Adams who wrote I must study
politics and war that my sons may have
Liberty to study mathematics and
philosophy my son's ought to study
matter math mathematics and philosophy
geography Natural History naval
architecture navigation Commerce and
agriculture in order to give their
children a right to study painting
poetry music architecture statuary
tapestry and porcelain you wouldn't have
guessed that one in the series would you
yet it's worth pointing out that even in
the sphere of the Arts we haven't done
too badly to speak only of literature
names like Walt Whitman Mark Twain Edith
Wharton Robert Frost and many others all
the tests that we have in fact done far
better than my generally have been
expected of a nation conceived primarily
to achieve other ends these ends were
social political and economic and it is
in them that we have indeed excelled the
most we have excelled by following our
founding fathers John Adams included in
directing our energies as our
Constitution sorted us to do to the
preservation of the blessings of liberty
to ourselves and our posterity as well
as to the pursuit of happiness tacitly
understood by the Declaration of
Independence to require prosperity as a
necessary precondition
in his original draft of the Declaration
of course check jefferson used the word
property instead of the pursuit of
happiness by remaining in spite of
lapses like affirmative action the
faithful in principle and to a
considerable extent in practice to the
ideas by which the founding fathers hope
to accomplish these ends we and our
forebears have fashioned the country in
which more Liberty and more prosperity
are more widely shared than among any
other people in the history of the human
race yes yes even today when policies
unfaithful both to the letter and to the
spirit of the traditional American
system have resulted in a series of
political and economic setbacks so far
as Liberty is concerned until recently
no one but radical libertarians ever
argued that we were insufficiently free
in these United States if anything some
conservatives dismayed by such phenomena
as the spread of pornography and sexual
license thought that we had too much
freedom for our own good but thanks to
Barack Obama's barely concealed
hostility to the free market his
takeover of a greater and greater share
of the American economy and the threat
posed by Obamacare to religious and
economic freedom many conservatives are
now echoing these libertarian arguments
if in a milder form indeed judging by
his record and the many many things he
has said Obama is not all that concerned
about liberty what he really cares about
and what he assigns a higher value to is
equality or as he once put it I actually
believed in redistribution yet here's
what the late daniel patrick moynihan
wrote in 1976 about this very issue in
connection with the redistributionist
ideology then regnant at the UN and now
pervasive in the in the Obama
administration
the political community supporting it
here's what Moynihan wrote an equality
what is the record the record was stated
most succinctly by an Israeli socialist
who told William F Buckley Jr that those
nations which have put Liberty ahead of
equality have ended up doing better and
by equality than those with the reverse
priority this is our case we are of the
liberty party and it might surprise us
what energies might be released were we
to unfurl those banners for years later
Ronald Reagan came along to unfurl those
banners and just as Moynihan predicted
the ultimate result was the release of
new political and economic energies that
reversed the decline of American
political and economic power presided
over by Jimmy Carter and that led to our
victory in the Cold War of course the
party of Liberty Moynihan was talking
about was the United States of America
and the party of equality was the
socialist countries of what was then
called the third world but within
America today an analogous split has
opened up with the Republicans
constituting the party of liberty and
the Democrats more and more becoming the
party of equality hence the Democrats
led by the President himself never
stopped claiming that the rich are
failing to pay their fair share of taxes
yet after surveying the numbers The
Economist Walter Williams of George
Mason University asks an excellent
question what standard of fairness
dictates that the 10 top percent of
income earners pay seventy one percent
of the federal income tax burden while
forty-seven percent of Americans pay
absolutely nothing to which an editorial
in the Wall Street Journal reporter
replies there is nothing fair about
confiscatory tax policy that reduces
growth denies opportunity and keeps more
people in poverty then too there's the
assumption blithely accepted by the
party of equality
that the gap between rich and poor or
even between the rich in the middle
class self-evidently amounts to a
violation of social justice yet far from
being self-evident this assumption stems
from a highly questionable concept of
social justice one that rules out or
minimizes the role played by talent
character ambition initiative daring
work and spirit that in reality produce
the unequal outcomes of the pursuit of
happiness okay furthermore both the
assumption and the correlative concept
of social justice held by the party of
equality run counter to the American
grain a study after study has shown and
as the petering out of the Occupy Wall
Street movement has recently reconfirmed
what Tocqueville observed on this point
in the 1830s remains true today
Americans unlike Europeans he said do
not hate the higher classes of society
even if they are not favorably inclined
toward them which is to say that most
Americans are not prone to the envy of
the rich that eats away at their
self-appointed spokesman on the left nor
are most Americans subject to the
accompanying passion for economic
egalitarianism that made for the spread
of socialism in other countries what
explains the absence of that leveling
passion is that it's been starved by the
opportunities America has afforded
millions upon millions to better their
lot and the advantage they have been
free to take of those opportunities and
this in turn explains how unprecedented
and unmatched levels of prosperity have
been created here and how they have come
to be shared more widely here than
anywhere else Tocqueville also put his
finger on another related reason for the
persistence of this particular feature
of American exceptionalism that's as
striking today as it was at the
beginning the word poor he wrote is used
here in a relative not an
absolute sense poor men in America would
often appear rich in comparison with the
poor of Europe well a story I was once
told by a Soviet dissident who had
managed to escape to America provides an
amusing illustration it seems that the
Soviet authorities used to encourage the
repeated screening of The Grapes of
Wrath the movie as you may remember
about the migration during the Great
Depression of the 1930s of starving
farmers in the Dust Bowl who were
struggling in their broken-down pickups
to reach California but contrary to
expectation what Soviet audiences got
from this film was not an impression of
how wretched was the plight of the poor
in America instead they came away
marveling that in America even the
peasants own trucks Tocqueville further
observed that in America and I'm quoting
now the poor instead of forming the
immense majority of the nation as is
always the case in our Socratic
communities are comparatively few in
number and the laws do not bind them
together by the ties of irremediable and
hereditary penury well as the great
economist and social critic Thomas soul
of the Hoover Institution has
demonstrated time and again it's still
the case that the poor in America are
comparatively few in number and except
for the black underclass who size is
generally estimated it's somewhere
between two and ten percent of the black
community and whose plight has thus far
resisted every attempt at alleviation
over the past 50 years is also true that
penury in the United States is neither
irremediable nor hereditary according to
Seoul of those who live on the next rung
of the economic ladder and a larger
number of whom are white and black only
three percent get stuck in the bottom
fifth of the income distribution for
more than eight years elaborating on
Seoul's analyses mark Perry the American
Enterprise Institute rights and on
quoting here in the discussions on
income inequality and wage stagnation we
frequently hear about the top 1% of the
top ten percent of the bottom ninety
nine percent and the public has started
to believe that those groups operate
like closed private clubs that contain
the exact same people or households
every year but the empirical evidence
tells a much different story of dynamic
change in the labor market people in
households move up and down the earnings
quintiles throughout their careers and
lives many of today's low-income
households will rise to become
tomorrow's high-income households and
some will even eventually be in the top
10% or the top 1% and many of today's
top 1% or top income quintile members
are tomorrow's middle or lower class
households reflecting the significant
upward and downward mobility in the
dynamic US labor market no such mobility
can be found in the members of the
European Union this is me speaking now
or anywhere else for that matter even in
the dismal economic state our nation has
fallen into today then it is still
exceptional with a degree and the
distribution of prosperity our concern
would appear however that Barack Obama
does not agree when asked whether he
believed in American exceptionalism he
took the question to mean whether he
believed in the superiority of this
country to all others and to this he in
effect said no quote I believe in
American exceptionalism just as I
suspect that the Brits believe in
British exceptionalism and the Greeks
and unfortunate choice believe in Greek
exceptionalism to which Mitt Romney
responded our president doesn't have the
same feelings about American
exceptionalism that we do Obama then
countered by indignantly denying that he
meant what he said about American
exceptionalism as is his wont
nevertheless there can be no doubt that
a very serious
difference about the nature of American
society separates Obama from Romney as
it does liberals from conservatives in
general with all exceptions duly noted I
think it's fair to say that what
liberals very much including Obama
mainly see when they look at America is
injustice and oppression of every kind
crying out for redress by sharp contrast
conservatives Mitt Romney most
definitely among them see a complex of
traditions and institutions built upon
the principles and animated the American
Revolution and that have made it
possible to say yet again what cannot be
said too often for more freedom and more
prosperity to be enjoyed by more of its
citizens than in any other society in
human history it follows that what
liberals believe needs to be changed or
discarded is precisely what
conservatives are dedicated to
preserving reinvigorating and defending
against attack from the ideologues on
the left who have no great regard for
those traditions and institutions and
who concentrate their attention on the
relatively little that is wrong with
America instead of the enormous good
embodied within it a similar divide
separates the attitudes of Obama and
Romney toward the role America has
played in world affairs just as Obama
denies that he said what he said about
American exceptionalism he also denies
that he ever issued the apologies he has
clearly issued but the misdeeds of which
he imagines we have been guilty in our
relations with other countries in
general and the Muslim world in
particular nevermind that the United
States has been an exceptionally
powerful force for good in the world at
large nevermind that we have spilled
blood and treasure to liberate and
protect many millions of people from the
totalitarian Horrors first of nazism
none of communism and that since nine
eleven we have spilled yet more
and treasurer fighting against Islam Oh
fascism the totalitarian successor to
Nazism and as to the Muslim world in
particular never mind that as the
columnist mona Charen puts it of the
last six wars in which the united states
was involved kuwait Bosnia Kosovo
Afghanistan Iraq and Libya for were
undertaken to rescue Muslims and the
other two afghanistan and iraq had the
side benefit of liberating Muslims and
she wisely adds two white to what end
remains an open question in spite of all
this the liberal community with Obama at
its head seems to think that the rest of
the world would be better off without us
or short of that if we were at least to
continue Obama's policy of leading from
behind admittedly there are paleo
conservatives like pat buchanan and
libertarians like ron paul who agree on
this point with obama but Mitt Romney is
emphatically not one of them and neither
do most conservatives wish for the
radical diminution of American power and
influence favored by Obama and his
supporters shortly before the election
of 2008 Obama declared that we were five
days away from what he described as a
fundamental transformation of America
but hard though he has tried I'll give
him that he is thus far fallen short of
fully realizing this ambition my fervent
hope is that on november six the
American people will deny him the chance
to wipe away as many more traces of
American exceptionalism as it will take
to turn this country into a facsimile of
the social democratic regimes of Western
Europe he so deluded ly wishes to
emulate my equally fervent matching hope
is that the president who succeeds him
will keep faith with his promise in his
own words to restore to this country the
principles that made this nation the
greatest nation in the history of Earth
the earth and I would add in my own
words that made it so exceptional yes
exceptional a force for good both at
home and abroad thank you very much
what a beautiful sound in the past 35
years Hillsdale College has given its
freedom leadership award to a few
individuals who have distinguished
themselves in defense of the good for
which the college was founded in its
1844 articles civil and religious
freedom among these individuals are
William Buckley Margaret Thatcher
Clarence Thomas whose wife my friend
Virginia is here stand up
and edwin meese the 3rd now the college
is honored to add to their number the
illustrious name of norman podhoretz
Norman has agreed to answer a few
questions with all humility if you have
a question could you please raise your
hand and one of the students with the
microphones will come to you present you
the microphone and then please answer
your question please ask your question
thank you driven everybody into silence
ah there's a what exactly was it that
led Henry Adams to make the change that
he made and his view towards America
well what happened was the radical
change that came over the country after
the Civil War when with the rapid
industrialization of the country and
then the influx of illiterate immigrants
who were needed for to supply the labor
that the industrialization required
which in turn gave rise to the political
machines in the cities this all seemed
just horribly degenerate as compared
with the America of the pre Civil War
period when men of quality and education
and taste were running that like his own
ancestors were running the country and
he became he turned 180 degrees in
response to these changes and made
exactly the same charges of gross
materialism and the vulgarity and
barbarism that he had so eloquently
refuted in the in the pre-civil war
period
mr. Hart's I wonder if you could comment
on the lack of time with the president
nited states meet with the Prime
Minister of Israel recently and American
exceptionalism and leadership in the
world America what is it exceptionalism
all right well I mean I don't blame the
president for not meeting with bebe
netanya after all he had to go on David
Letterman's show and this is only the
latest in a series of gestures of
symbolic and substantive that Obama has
made since he came into office with the
declared purpose of how did he once put
it putting some light between US and
Israel on the theory that George W Bush
had been too close to the Israelis and
that this made the the peace process
so-called more difficult to to achieve
its hope for result and it was also part
of the of his new conception of the
Muslim world in general which got
expressed in this notorious famous first
but now notorious speech in Cairo in
which he fundamentally apologized for
our misdeeds and relation to the Muslim
world and he's done one thing after
another and consistent with that
attitude it it's a I mean in my judgment
apart from everything else apart from
any ideological considerations it's an
immensely foolish policy because it's
based on a series of assumptions that
have been proved over and over and over
again to be false I mean to put it in
simplest terms what the problem in the
relation between Israel and the
Palestinians and and the surrounding
Arab states is not an equal contest
between equally misguided parties which
is
most foreign ministries including our
own State Department believe what we
have here is a war against Israel that
was launched from the minute Israel was
born in 1948 and that has continued by
various means hot and cold ever since
and it is a war with the declared
objective not hidden by except when it's
prudent to do so in diplomatic context
to wipe Israel off the map because the
feeling is that Israel is an abomination
in the eyes of Islam not supposed to
have this is a territory belonging to
Islam and that viewing you and to have
any any other sovereignty existing there
especially Jewish sovereignty is an
offence in the eyes of God in addition
to which Israel is seen by them as a an
arm of the colonial imperialist powers
led by the United States now there's
going to be no peace in that part of the
world that is to say no peace between
Israel and the I mean they've been 22
Wars by the way in the Middle East since
the founding of Israel in which Israel
was not involved although people keep
saying that the Israeli conflict with
the Palestinians is the main source of
instability in the region so ridiculous
but there will be peace if there ever
will be when the when the arab-muslim
world decides to call off the war that
it declared in 1948 I mean someday this
may happen if it happens they can be
peace the very next day until it happens
there is no way there's going to be
peace and Israel will only be forced to
make concession after me concession
which will make it weaker without
bringing peace any closer or someone
said everyone knows down deep that
if the Arabs laid down their arms there
would be peace and if the Israelis lay
down their arms there would be genocide
and that about sums the position up so
it's an unwise policy and I mean if
there were more time I could wax I would
try to wax eloquent on the reasons that
this nation should remain committed to
not only Israel's survival but it's it's
flourishing and and millions and
millions of Americans understand this
very well especially evangelical
Protestants who have become more
pro-israel than even the Jewish
community well thank God for that I i
was telling Larry earlier that when i
think of the jewish vote for obama
seventy-eight percent in in 2008 and
apparently climbing again for some in
expo i I paraphrase what Jefferson said
about slavery said I tremble for my
nation my country when I reflect that
God is just I sometimes say I tremble
for my people when I reflect that God is
just not funny but it's witty I think
last question and here we go yeah okay I
see thank you very much for your
thoughtful remarks I have a question
about whether there's a significant flaw
in the Constitution in this sense that
the passage of Obamacare which is just
the latest in a hundred years of
progressive imprudence even if the
Republican Party would take the house
and senate in the presidency because of
the extraordinary majority you need in
the Senate and because of the Supreme
Court's decision can you reverse some of
these decisions that are made when
people start to be given benefits and
programs and that sort of thing well the
answer is it be very very difficult but
it's not impossible and it's not
unconscious
you know I mean it's a technical
question basically I mean there are some
experts who think that you don't need a
two-thirds majority in the Senate that a
simple majority would be enough I don't
know whether that's true but I do know
that at least in theory and in principle
it it is reversible in practice it may
be very very difficult to do and that
would be a calamity but we can only work
toward toward that goal and hope and
pray that it will be accomplished before
it before it half ruins the country I
that's a very low note on which the end
so why don't I just say God bless
america